NASA is celebrating this morning after a
ground very groundbreaking artificial
intelligence helped discover a new
planet and ask the researchers used
advanced machine learning technology
from Google to find the planet thousands
of light-years away called kepler 90i
it's in a solar system similar to ours
Michelle Miller explains how the new
technology could impact the search for
alien life and another habitable planet
Michelle good morning good morning this
is super exciting for us space geeks out
there because NASA researchers have
known about this faraway solar system
for some time but it's how the discovery
of this new planet was made that has the
scientific community very optimistic in
the neverending search for life beyond
planet Earth NASA scientists have
uncovered the only other a planet solar
system they know of that circles a Sun
with help from Google and their machine
learning computer software scientists
analyzed thousands of data points
captured from this NASA planet-hunting
Space Telescope the Kepler that data
helped researchers discover this new
planet Kepler 90i having all this data
coming from Kepler for scientists is
like trying to drink from a fire hose
astronomer Derek Pitts says it's the way
the new planet was discovered that has
scientists buzzing and makes their jobs
easier the Google AI system has been
able to search through that pile of
information much faster than humans have
been able to dig through it if you think
about the analogy of the number of stars
in a galaxy being like the number of
sand grains on a beach it says if we've
been asked to search through all the
sand grains on the beach to find just
the red sand grains like Earth Kepler
90i is the third planet from its Sun in
an a planet system but unlike earth the
temperature on the surface of this
planet is about 800 degrees Fahrenheit
which is far too hot for the possible
development of life as we know it it's
about 2,500 light years away that means
even traveling at the speed of light it
would take us 2,500 years just to get
there yeah the current rocking
technology can't quite you know move in
that direction and it would take us
millions of years just to reach kepler
90 as he said the new planet also orbits
the star about every 14 days which means
you'd have a birthday just about every
two weeks which I don't have a problem
with would you
I mean come to stay right here there's a
chance yeah you know there are other
possibilities of hiding planets in that
system so you never know they just found
this one but 800 degrees that's a lot of
sunscreen you gotta wear to block that I
didn't know you were a science geek I'm
still thinking about that